what is up everybody its Anna Mike here
for anime uproar and today I will be
delving deep into the abyss of demon
magic with black clover the current
story arc is absolute fire that goes
without saying at this point but in the
most recent chapter is the true identity
of some of the most important demons has
been revealed and we just got more
information about Austin's anti magic
demon and his backstory the fight
between Austin Dante is gaining steam
one member of the black balls is
fighting for his life and things
couldn't be any more epic so let's get
into it
if you enjoyed the black clover content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it go and please leave a like to let me
know it really helps me and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar or you
just haven't subscribed please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications I'm big thank you to all
of our animal prope treants who make
videos like this one possible I'll talk
more about patreon at the end of this
video but first please be advised that
this video will contain black clover
manga spoilers I mean I think this is
pretty clear already but just in case I
want to remind everyone that I will be
talking about the very latest
developments in the black lower stories
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned
as hasta unleashes his brand-new demon
form the form that was introduced in the
previous chapter Vanessa says that all
the magic that has been affecting the
area around them has suddenly
disappeared
I wonder if Austin's new form was able
to unlock some sort of anti mana zone
the anti magic version of mana zone
which has the power to cancel out all
the magic in a certain area if that is
what just happened then this definitely
signals a new chapter in the development
of Austin's power just imagine what a
powerful anti mana zone could do it
could allow us to negate the magic of
dozens of mages at the same time within
a given area perhaps hasta will even be
able to cancel out the magic of an
entire army once he learns to fully
control this immense power you know like
the spade army for example all in all
this
new form that hasta is using is
definitely no joke and we see that hasta
is now able to extend the effects of his
anti magic even further and use his
powers even faster and this allows him
to go toe-to-toe with the demon king
dante himself at least for the time
being however dante is able to dodge all
of Austin's new overpowered moves
including his sword based attacks
furthermore in this new demon form hasta
appears to have gone completely berserk
just like Dante wanted hasta seems to
have given in to his emotions after
witnessing what happened to gauche and
so this new hasta is definitely a lot
stronger than he was before but he is
also a lot less rational he's like a
wild beast focused only on destroying
Dante and this is exactly what Dante
wanted to happen
but even though Dante is still able to
effectively dodge Oscar's attacks
without much trouble seeing Asta's anti
magic power in action piques Dante's
curiosity dante decides to communicate
with his own demon directly and in that
moment
Dante's demons name is revealed his name
is Lucifer or Lucifer o depending on the
translation that's right Dante's demon
bears the very name that is often used
to refer to the biblical devil in
Christianity I find this to be highly
appropriate since Dante basically just
tempted hasta into giving in to his
emotions in order to unlock his new
demon form and that of course is very
similar to how the devil of the Bible
Lucifer tempts humans the devil of the
Bible is known for tempting Jesus in the
desert and some interpretations of the
Bible also believe that the devil was
the one who took the form of a serpent
and tempted Adam and Eve in the Garden
of Eden the devil of the Bible wants to
tempt humans to give in to their base
desires their negative emotions and
their greed Dante seems to be interested
in the very same thing he believes that
being evil is the true nature of
humanity the one thing that makes them
different from all other animals and
Dante firmly believes in embrace
seeing all of your toxic negative
emotions in the name of gaining power
Dante asks Lucifer about the demon who
is possessing hasta but Lucifer doesn't
know who this anti magic demon is
Lucifer says that in terms of the higher
rank demons the only one who is in this
world but not affiliated with the Spade
kingdom is Zog red and zag red is
revealed to be the true name of the
kotodama demon
however Lucifer says that Zog red is not
a Staz demon Asta's demon is someone
else
Lucifer states that a demon who lacks
mana and uses anti magic must be a lower
ranked demon and Dante concludes that
Asta's demon will be no threat to him
because all the members of the dark
triad are possessed by the very highest
ranked demons but regardless of the fact
that his demon is apparently a lower
ranked demon Austin still continues to
show impressive power in his fight
against the Dante anti-magic who's as
out of asta swords and the dark energy
is able to extend itself far beyond
Austin's body essentially turning his
swords into long-range weapons the dark
anti magic energy expands from the
swords and zigzags all over the place
clashing with Dante's gravity magic in
what is clearly an epic showdown even
Vanessa is shocked by the tremendous
scope of the battle between Berserker
auste and demon king dante Vanessa knows
that at this point austin's demon is out
of control and hasta has gone berserk
hasta may not have full control of his
actions anymore
and he is acting more like an angry wild
beast than a human but Vanessa also
knows that they have no choice but to
rely on hasta no one else can even come
close to standing up to Dante and even
though Austin definitely doesn't have
the upper hand on Dante by any means
hasta is at least holding his own for
now which is certainly more than any of
the other black bulls who are currently
present could do meanwhile gauche is
still not dead but he is definitely in
big trouble
the massive sword wound to his chest is
a very severe life-threatening injury
and there isn't much that Vanessa and
gray can do for him gray in particular
is very upset that her transformation
magic happens to be completely useless
in a situation like this but that is the
reality of the black clover world
everyone's magic is well suited for
something but not everyone is going to
be a healing magic expert although I
will say that this brief scene showing
gray being so upset may be foreshadowing
that she will develop some sort of new
spell or magical ability in the future
that may end up being useful to gauche
that's just speculation on my part
though I might be reading too much into
this little scene but we'll have to wait
and see back to the battle
Dante appears to be pretty much
untouched by osdas attacks although he
is definitely impressed that hasta
continues to struggle an attack over and
over again even though all of his
efforts have been pretty fruitless so
far but then hasta uses a jacked up
version of black hurricane and the anti
magic that is generated is able to track
where dante will appear next as a result
hasta is able to land his first real
blow on Dante a scratch on the side of
Dante's face Dante is shocked that hasta
was actually able to injure him and that
is where this insane chapter ends to me
personally it seems that Dante is still
far stronger than hasta but Austin's new
form has definitely been an impressive
powerup and it is now possible that
Austin will be able to keep Dante busy
at least until Yami returns if we assume
that Dante is at least as strong as
Zenon although as the leader of the dark
triad he might be even stronger it is
safe to assume that Austin's new form
puts him at a power level that is
significantly above everyone in the
Golden Dawn including you know none of
the members of the Golden Dawn stood a
chance against Zenon and yet the new and
improved hasta is holding his own
against Dante although to be fair
hasta is still a massive underdog with
that said even if asta manages to keep
Dante busy long enough for
reinforcements to arrive it may already
be too late for gosh
after Ghosh's terrible injury in the
previous chapter this chapter did at
least confirm that he is still alive
barely Ghosh's injuries so severe that
he might die at any time in short of
some massive Aspel he probably will
likely die if this happens then the
black balls will be more motivated than
ever to destroy the dark triad but I
have to say that would feel really bad
for Murray
if gauche died Murray has already lost
both her parents and she faced a lot of
hardship as a child and for a long time
Ghosh had been the only person in
Murray's life who actually cared about
her Murray has definitely made some
friends now including the Black Bulls
but before that Ghosh had to risk his
life to help his sister survived and
Ghosh's death would absolutely devastate
the poor girl I freely admit that it
doesn't look too good for Ghosh at the
moment but I also feel that Murray has
been through so much already oh man this
sucks and since we're on the topic of
Ghosh's tragic injury a bunch of you
commented on my previous video that you
wanted me to discuss the brief panel
that appeared to show Asta's memory of
his mother
it seems that Ghosh's chest injury
sparked Austin's memory and he saw a
brief glimpse of his own mother with
blood coming out of her mouth and a
large wound in her chest speaking the
words my dear son I was going to make a
separate video about this so I was
holding off on talking about it but
because of all your comments I feel that
I have to address it here we know how
baby you know got to the orphanage in
Haggai village and we know why he was
placed there but we still don't know why
baby hasta ended up in the same place at
the same time obviously the fact that
I'll stay ended up next to you no
implies that hasta has some connection
to you know and to the Spade Kingdom but
we don't know what exactly that
connection is since Austin's mother was
apparently gravely injured around the
same time that you know was smuggled out
of the spade Kingdom this implies that
Austin's mom was involved in the fight
against the dark triad she may have also
been a member of House grin burial or
she may have been loyal to the House
Greenberry all and fought on their side
against the dark triad based on that
brief glimpse of a memory that hasta had
we can conclude that Austin's mother
probably died as a result of the injury
she sustained in the battle against the
dark triad and that is why I asked ended
up as an orphan alongside you know in
hog a village I know that a lot of
people really don't want asta to end up
having some special bloodline or
anything like that
and it may well be that Austin's mother
was just a loyal soldier or servant of
house grin burial that would make hasta
just a commoner but a commoner of the
Spade Kingdom rather than the clover
kingdom or there could be more to the
story after all baby hasta was found
right next to the rightful Prince of the
Spade Kingdom baby you know it's
possible that hasta is not just any
commoner and that his connection to
Prince you know is deeper than just
being the son of you knows parents
servants but we'll have to wait and see
definitely let me know what you guys
think about the whole ask the parent
situation and why baby
hasta ended up next to baby you know at
the orphanage in Hogg a village this is
one of the bigger mysteries in the
series right now and I'm definitely
interested in finding out more also how
are you liking Austin's new berserker
form and are you enjoying the epic fight
against Dante as much as I am please
give me your thoughts on the current
state of the black clover story down in
the comments below if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more black
clover content on the channel please
leave a like to let me know and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar or you
just haven't subscribed yet please
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications I want to
give a big thank you to all of our anime
upper patrons for making videos like
this one possible with YouTube
constantly facing problems left and
right patron support means more than
ever thank you guys so much
first and foremost I want to thank our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all other clans including Ingrid
ah al Olin Adam the world Steelers the
school bus tyson karina acquired respect
and pat a heffa and i can't forget our
pro hero to your patrons including the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Odin Anatoly kazansky alpha
do on hell Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan
Kapoor cricket XP $30 beat
Ted no Ted Joel - Joel Stanton very
Gucci Jessica Kay Lafond
Alicia Akhter emperor otaku and JCCC
walk up if you guys enjoy our videos and
you feel that they provide value for you
please consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]